demandez à annie maintenant ce qu'elle
en pense parce que dany à une jeune
fille qui doit avoir pratiquement l'âge
de baiona
comment ça se passe passé ce moment
c'est facile d'élever un métier qui
n'est peut-être pas le métier de tout le
monde mais vous ne projetons que ça
devrait pas changer je pense que je
pense que les rapports des enfants leur
façon de voir la vie et que ça n'a rien
à voir avec le métier et les parents
font je crois pas je crois si l'on il ya
une bonne entente à la maison qu'on les
aime ou qu'on les respecte surtout je
pense qu'au contraire moi ma fille
m'étonne beaucoup je veux dire qu'elle
est elle sait très bien ce qu elle le
fait elle sait pas exactement ce qu'elle
fera comme métier mais je veux dire elle
sait reconnaître les choses je la
respecte complètement
je pense qu'elle va faire sa vie de
femme et c'est assez tels que ça regarde
ce n'est pas moi par contre je lui donne
toutes les possibilités d'être bien être
bien elle même de ne pas de pouvoir se
défendre s'il y à se défendre et de
jouir de la vie d'être bien d'être
normal ça se sait ce que c'est l'apanage
de ces gosses c'est que parmi nos
invités au